when you're leading many people
if you've always got to be the one who
knows the answer you become the
constriction in the pipe
because your team can only advance as
quickly as your own knowledge allows so
this is where the curiosity and listing
comes in instead of being focused on
knowing the answer
great leaders are those who are focused
on asking the important questions
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
let's learn how to lead from the jump
seat
meet peter docker
peter teaches people how to navigate the
challenge of leadership his latest book
leading from the jump seat delivers the
message that leadership is about lifting
people up and giving them the space they
need to sow that when the time is right
they can take the lead
co-author of find your why and formerly
a founding igniter at simon sinek inc
peter draws on his 25-year career in the
royal air force and over 14 years spent
partnering with businesses around the
world to inspire others to lead from the
jump seat
to learn more about leading from the
jumpsuit go to
leadingfromthejumpseat.com
peter i have to start out you know just
understanding a little bit about
you know why why focus you know why
dedicate your career to this question of
leadership you know how where does this
stem from you know some people want to
be firemen when they grow up some people
want to have you know they have
different specializations and jobs and
you dedicate your career to harnessing
human potential and human talent and
helping others where does that really
come from for you
well it's not like i set out to do that
michael you know i think uh for many
years particularly the 25 years i was in
the royal air force um it's just
something that i did but not that
intentionally if you see what i mean you
know we're focused on uh the work that
we were doing i was a pilot i led people
in combat
and other interesting situations shall
we say but
it wasn't as if i was thinking
specifically about leadership at the
time but it's only later on in life that
i've had the opportunity to sit back
and reflect and identify those times
when it didn't go quite so well as well
as the times that really
did fly well
and codify it and also i've had the
opportunity over the past what 10-15
years
since leaving the air force to
well visit 93 countries and work with
leadership teams from companies in
practically every sector you can imagine
so my curiosity has kept me alive and
helped to inform what i see as great
leadership and when it doesn't work so
well either
right and so
where are you more curious about the way
that it what makes great leadership or
what makes it not work so well
well
first of all i don't think there is any
such thing as a perfect leader
you know in my book leading from the
jump seat i mentioned a few times when
i certainly did not get it right
and in some ways i think oh if only i
knew what i knew now but of course it's
by making those mistakes that we
actually learn provided
we remain curious and provided we remain
reflective and focus less on the
individual data points but more on the
overall trend where are we sourcing
ourselves from
you know we source ourselves from a
place of fear
or a place of love ultimately which i
know gets people a bit twitchy in a
business environment when i mention
about love but when we are um source
ourselves from a place of love we're
looking at the world as a place of
possibility and opportunity we're
looking at
the chance to lift people up rather than
focusing on ourselves and we suppress
that ego so it doesn't get in the way
you know so that's what i mean by
leaning from love and that's what's
really important to source ourselves
from that place rather than fear
and also to go a little bit easy on
ourselves where we don't get it right
you know as i say it's the overall trend
over time that's important rather than
any one specific data point where we
might not have got it quite right yeah
curiosity and reflectivity two things
that you mentioned in the beginning here
you know what what do we know about them
well what if you understood about
curiosity and reflectivity and and where
in your life did this come about where
you really understood that these two
elements are are some of the most
crucial elements to become effective
leaders on an ongoing basis and not just
in in very specific moments
well i think one of the key aspects of
the great leaders that i've known and
i've worked had the privilege of working
with many
is that they listen
and you can only listen properly if
you're curious about something
and so the great leaders i've worked
with they've been curious about my view
about my perception of a situation and
what i can contribute
and that curiosity has them listen
intensely to their people and it
empowers their people here's the thing
often we are well our whole system when
we go through school college we are
rewarded by knowing the answer
yeah you're a specialist in your field
and you become a specialist because you
get good at a certain area and you
you're the go-to person you know the
answer but here's the thing when you're
leading many people
if you've always got to be the one
who knows the answer you become the
constriction in the pipe
because your team can only advance as
quickly as your own knowledge allows so
this is where the curiosity and listing
comes in instead of being focused on
knowing the answer
great leaders are those who are focused
on asking the important questions
and feeling confident to lead when they
don't know the answer
because when you're confident the lead
in that situation you're no longer that
constriction in the pipe and instead
you're leaning into your people your
team and that collective genius
who can step up and contribute to
figuring out the answers that you need
and that is why i think curiosity and
the ability to really listen
to the answers to the questions that you
ask is so important in any leader
now is this something that can be
trained or taught you know to be curious
the art of being curious because it
sounds to me is that it's not enough to
just say yes i want to know more about
it but there you have to have it and a
really intrinsic motivation to
understand and a wanting to understand
especially when you know you think you
know the answer but but you really do
want to know what the other person is
thinking even though you're sure you're
right is this something that really i
can train myself to do better
yes i think it is and it starts with
self-reflection you know
i i start the book by taking a deep dive
into figuring out
what is really important
to us as individuals i'm not talking
about latest you know iphone or whatever
it happens to be or paycheck no what is
deeply important to you now for many of
us that's family but when we start to
dig deeper there are other things that
we can identify that are very important
to us for me
the choices i made while i went to
university to study the subjects i did
the reason i studied those subjects was
because my parents were had both lost
their jobs and very hard up and i wanted
to be able to get a good job to support
them and also not to be a burden on them
so that was one key thing that was
revealed as something deeply important
to me there's something else that
happened as well which revealed uh
another aspect which is deeply important
to me which is the notion of mutual
respect
now
the reason that it's so valuable to
identify those deeply important things
to you
is that it builds a reservoir of energy
that helps you to step forward even into
the unknown i'll give you an example i
mentioned family a couple of years ago i
had a call from my wife and she'd been
involved in a car accident i dropped
everything there was nothing that was
going to get in my way
to going and supporting my wife now i
didn't know what i would find i stepped
into the unknown but i was absolutely
committed to moving forward
and it's that energy that helped build
that momentum to go and support my wife
no questions asked and so when we
identify those other choices that we've
made in life which collectively show us
what's deeply important to us
it gives us that energy to move forward
and this is where it links in to the
curiosity piece
if we are deeply passionate about
certain things
those
handrails that guide us even in the
unknown
then we are naturally likely to become
curious because we want to learn as much
as we can to solve the challenges in
front of us
and when we have that linked to that
passion it suppresses something else as
well which is important it suppresses
ego
because ego can get in our way and
instead we can learn to lead with what i
call
humble confidence
and that is what we need when we are
curious and we're comfortable not
knowing the answer
but absolutely focused on asking the
important questions
where do we see this humbled confidence
in today's world what are some examples
are there with specific people
organizations that you've observed you
know figures that really embody this
idea of humbled confidence
well um let's go large you know there's
a company that i write quite extensively
about uh called asos and asos is a
british company uh it is in the fashion
retail business they are huge
yeah they've got something like um 400
000 products available online
they distribute to over 200 countries
and territories
every day they add 5 000 products
to their website you know this is big
and until pretty recently the
ceo the guy in charge is a chap called
nick benton
and nick is
an example of everything that i write
about in the book and he displays humble
confidence so what is humble confidence
humble confidence as the word suggest is
first of all let's look at the
confidence side it's about being
confident in your own strengths
absolutely resolute
about where you're going
with your team your organization your
company
whilst um
also being ready to make the decisions
when they need to be taken
but then the humble side of it comes in
it's having the humility to listen to
others having the humility to recognize
that we don't have all the answers but
seeing that as a strength rather than a
weakness and this is how nick bayton
over the years he was with the company
about 15 i think grew it from a very
small company to a multi-billion
dollar
consortium across the world
and
he did this by lifting up his own people
by empowering them this is a key tenant
of what i call jump seat leadership you
know leadership jumpseek leadership is
not about retaining or growing your own
power
it's about lifting others up and
empowering them
so when the time is right they can take
the lead and that takes a large degree
of humble confidence
what is the most challenging piece of
doing exactly what you mentioned you
know
not retaining not holding all the power
to you but but but and but you know
harnessing it for others and making sure
that they're
leveraged to to leverage this power and
to grow themselves and become their own
individual leaders what what is the most
challenging piece of it and i'm asking
this you know is from the lens of a
young entrepreneur looking to build my
own team pretty soon
in a startup scene and i want all of
them to be their own leaders as well
yeah
um i think the biggest challenge i've
already mentioned the world it's ego
you know uh
you're calling me from from cyprus at
the moment and many speak greek and ego
is greek for i
and
ego is generated
when fear is triggered now fear is
triggered when our life is in danger and
it does a good job you know it saves us
from the oncoming vehicle because we
jump out the way but fear is also
triggered when our livelihood our status
or our reputation
feels under threat and when it's
triggered because of one of those three
reasons often the reaction can be ego we
close down
we start seeing the world not as a place
of opportunity but as a place of
scarcity where i've got to win at all
costs no matter anything else
it's where we stop thinking about other
people and we're focusing on ourselves
alone
and the trouble with ego when it's
generated by fear
because we feel our livelihood stages or
reputations on the line
is that it's not sustainable fear acting
from fear is not sustainable
but there is an option and that option
is we always have the choice to choose
love
to choose humble confidence humble
confidence is the antidote to ego yeah
and because it comes from a place of
love it is sustainable it will keep us
going even when times are difficult even
when times are very tight you know
another entrepreneur
elon musk
when he started spacex you know he
started in 2006 he launched his first
rocket exploded 33 seconds after takeoff
he had another go in 2007 another
explosion 2008 more explosions
excuse me
fourth attempt
it flew
but then on his birthday in 2015 another
explosion where he lost two payloads for
nasa but here's the thing he said when
something is important enough you will
do it anyway even when the odds are not
in your favor and this links back to
what we're saying about being very clear
on what's deeply important to you
but also having a willingness to sort
yourself from a place of love for
something using humble confidence rather
than the fear of something where you can
be triggered by ego
so controlling that ego is so important
fascinating if we're looking at
you know leadership over the last few
decades and you've been examining and
you've been experiencing yourself has
this evolved at all you know the
different questions of leadership or
leadership styles in other words can we
expect leadership to continue evolving
or is this something that as humanity
we're sort of converging on this idea
and this is something that has taken us
you know since the beginning of human
nature and will continue to be to be
this pretty much with the same
principles moving forward i i think um
the finesse of it might change the
environment can change a little but
in my view uh the the main tenets of of
leadership uh hold steady throughout
time
leadership is underpinned by a clear
commitment to accomplish something and
commitment all the commitment is
is a promise we make to ourselves it's
not about contracts you know if you and
i signed a contract michael if one of us
wanted to back out we'd find a way of
backing out a commitment is only a
promise that we make to ourselves to
follow through
and then having the humble confidence to
listen to others as we discussed but the
last aspect of leadership which i think
is enduring
is to nurture a sense of belonging
as human beings we are inclined to
belong we want to belong
yeah
and leaders who nurture that sense of
belonging they create an environment
where people choose to step up and take
responsibility they choose to do more
for the cause whatever it happens to be
because they feel they belong they know
how their jigsaw puzzle piece can fit
into the overall picture on the box
and that's when
leadership really well starts to fly
because we find that we actually need to
lead less
and uh
our people don't need managing so much
either yeah so i yes the environment
might change you know
i love it they have a sense of belonging
sense of belonging is key
absolutely key
and you know i love to compress things
right down to the simplest thing
i'm a father now even if you're not a
father michael
you've been a a son
yeah and i think parenting is one of the
greatest leadership challenges
any of us can face
and let's look at it you know when you
first become a parent there's a whole
bunch of stuff that you don't know but
you are absolutely committed to bringing
up your children and having them
continue forward honoring those things
that you feel are deeply important yeah
you are willing to step into the unknown
even when you don't know the answers you
have the humble confidence to ask others
whether it's your your your friends your
own parents uh siblings who've got kids
to figure out how to bring up your
children and it's an enduring commitment
which stays with you until the day that
you die
so you know i think great leadership
starts as a parent great leadership
starts at home and the fundamental
aspects of leadership have not changed
over the centuries
incredible peter i really want to thank
you for
your time and your energy and for the
amazing work that you're doing you know
i really really in the way that i'm
seeing advanced humanity and advance you
know us and at the end you know
being a good leader is not just about
improving our own lives but it's about
empowering all those around us and i can
only hope for myself to to to be able to
harness some of the things that that
you're talking about here like humbles
confidence and and creating a sense of
belonging and putting ego aside and
being much more curious but truly truly
curious and being reflective so i'm
taking a lot of these concepts from this
conversation and it was short but it was
very meaningful to me so thank you very
much peter and i look forward to reading
the book myself leading from the
jumpsuit and then the incredible journey
that you've been on so thank you very
very much and stay safe and stay home my
absolute pleasure nice talking to you
michael take care
[Music]